i'm in trouble
you stole from me freddy
freddy what's the plan man i got the
money i got to think man
[Music]
dad
we are in trouble a bit shot
because i'm the only one that can help
you am i right what time do you get in
you need to come back you made a big
mistake
chrissy i need to get some money to my
daughter
he already got mac
mac won't be enough
how much blood have you lost
are you a gangster why are you on a bus
wasn't my intention initially
are you a cop you assume you know what i
want are we gonna have a
problem i know this guy at the bar
and he's going to get us where we need
to go
let's do this thing
get him and bring him here
listen to me man i'm telling you they're
on me just get to the station
don't answer the phone for nobody
don't stop
you're gonna be real gentle
damn
you need to come back
or i could pay christine and lily a
visit you still got the money
i wish things didn't have to go down
like this
[Music]
they want blood
[Music]
you